So that's the basic narrative I was here
and I'm trying to go there and so if
you're asking your kindergarten kid what
they did today at school and teaching
them to tell a story,
they might say,
well I was at home and then
mom took me to kindergarten.
It's like not a very exciting story
but it's a story and then a little more
exciting story might be
I was at home,
my mom took me to school and on the way
there are big dog ran up to the fence
and barked at me and the right question
that would follow that story is,
okay,
what did you do?
And that's a real story
because the kid says,
well look,
I was in this frame of reference and I
was aiming at goal a B actually I was
aiming at point B and while I was aiming
at point B an acting out the processes
that would lead me there,
something unexpected happened.
That's a story.
And then you say,
well what did you do?
And the kid might say,
well,
you know,
I was really scared and I hid behind mum
or so that would be one response and we
still went to kindergarten and I was okay,
it's pretty good,
pretty good.
Or The kid might say,
well I wasn't scared at all because
I know that if you stand up to dogs,
they usually leave you alone.
And we went to kindergarten
and that was okay.
And you know,
the kid is trained to tell really they're
trying to tell a little hero story and
if they're successful in the accounter
with the thing that's unknown,
then they triumph as a consequence of
their encounter with the unexpected.
And poof,
you know that's successful at a pace.
You Pat them on the head and you say,
yeah,
that's really good.
They kind of smile and you
know you're teaching them,
you're teaching them how to comprehend
their existence in a narrative structure
and you're also teaching them what
that narrative structure should be.
So this is like a Meta narrative and the
Meta narrative says you were going from
point a to point B.
That's the oval on that left.
And then something
completely bizarre happened.
Like I was betrayed and then I was in
this terrible place for quite a long
period of time,
a chaotic place.
But I learned a bunch and I put myself
back together and I'm a wiser person as a
consequence of the encounter,
right?
Everyone knows that story.
And that's paradise.
Paradise lost,
paradise regained.
It's a cultural meta-narrative and,
and it's a story that every,
like it's a human story.
It's an apocalyptic story.
That's why everybody's always
all apocalyptic about everything,
right?
Apocalypse of the week,
we're going to run out of oil,
we're going to run out of gas.
There's too much carbon dioxide.
The Chinese are going
to take over the world.
We're ruining the Co.
We're ruining the ecology,
the oceans running out of fish.
You know,
the world is getting too hot.
It was getting too cold in
1970 when I was about your age.
It's like apocalypse of the week.
Why?
Because things fall apart and because
they can fall apart completely and they
often do.
And so everyone's always on the alert
for like the next potential apocalypse.
And it's no wonder,
you know,
a permanent characteristic of life
that things can radically fall apart.
Now,
luckily it's a permanent characteristic
of life that they can actually also
radically come back together.
And it turns out that whether or
not they radically come together,
depends to some degree on how you
choose to act when they fall apart.